Well, last time we had seen
that when you write this
electron configuration,
that that electron
configuration is a shorthand way
of writing the wave functions
for the electrons in a
multi-electron atom within this
one electron wave approximation.
But we also noted that at most
we gave, or we assigned a
hydrogen-like wave function to
two electrons.
And we noted that that was
because of something you already
knew about called spin.
And spin, we saw last time,
was a quantum mechanical
phenomenon.
Spin is the intrinsic angular
momentum, built into the
particle.
And we saw that that spin is
designated by a fourth quantum
number.
That fourth quantum number here
is m sub s,
and it had two allowed values,
and those allowed values were
one half and minus one half.
And we said that those two
allowed values or those two
states represented a spin up and
a spin down.
Two different polarities,
in a sense, of this quantum
mechanical phenomenon called
spin.
How was spin actually
experimentally observed?
Well, really thanks to these
two gentlemen.
Here is Uhlenbeck and Goudsmit.
These were very young
scientists.
I think post-docs at the time.
And what they were doing was
looking at the emission spectra
from sodium atoms.
And this is 1925,
and so they knew enough,
already, to know at what
frequency they should expect to
see some emission.
And so they looked at the
emission, dispersed it,
looked at that frequency.
And instead of seeing emission
at that particular frequency
where they expected,
they saw, so if this is the
expected, what they really saw
was some emission at a little
bit lower frequency and some
emission at a little bit higher
frequency.
Not much but a little bit lower
and a little bit higher.
And in spectroscopy,
this kind of emission is
actually called the doublet.
Well, they were quite excited
about it, and thought much about
the reason why there might be a
doublet.
And they reasoned that they
could explain that doublet if
the electron were existing in
one of two states,
one of two spin states.
This was revolutionary.
And so they took their results
excitedly to the resident
established scientist that was
closest, who was Wolfgang Pauli.
And Wolfgang Pauli was not a
nice man, but they told Wolfgang
Pauli about what they saw.
And Wolfgang said,
rubbish, you publish that and
you will destroy your scientific
careers.
And so they left,
dejectedly.
No sooner had the door shut,
than Wolfgang sat down and
wrote a paper on the presence of
a fourth quantum number,
m sub s.
One of the travesties,
really, in the history of
science.
That is well known now.
But it really did take,
though, Dirac,
another three years later,
to actually show where this m
sub s came from,
this fourth quantum number came
from.
He had to use the relativistic
Schrödinger equation,
which we didn't look at.
He solved that.
And when he solved that,
out drops this fourth quantum
number, m sub s.
But Pauli did make a
contribution.
He worked on this problem,
and worked on the theoretical
basis of it, and in the end came
out with something called the
Pauli exclusion principle.
And the Pauli exclusion
principle, here,
simply says that no two
electrons in the same atom can
have the same electron wave
function and the same spin.
Or another way to state that,
is that no two electrons in the
same atom can have the same set
of four quantum numbers.
For example,
in our electron configuration
here for neon,
we've got two electrons in this
1s state.
Well, this electron here has
the quantum numbers (1,0,0,1/2).
This electron,
also in that 1s state,
has the quantum numbers
(1,0,0,-1/2) .
So the n, l and m quantum
numbers are the same for these
two electrons.
But what is different is the
spin quantum number.
One is one half and the other
is minus one half,
according to the Pauli
exclusion principle that says
you cannot have two electrons in
the same atom with the same set
of four quantum numbers.
And likewise,
for example,
this electron right here,
quantum numbers (2,1,-1,
+1/2).
But this electron,
quantum numbers (2 1,
-1, -1/2).
No two electrons have the same
set of four quantum numbers.
So that's why when we were
actually writing this electron
configurations,
which is the shorthand
representation for the wave
functions in the one-electron
approximation for these
multi-electron atoms,
that's why we didn't give the
ten electrons in neon,
for example,
we didn't all give that a 1s
hydrogen-like wave function.
Okay.
Now, what we want to do is we
want to take a look at what the
wave functions for the
individual electrons in a
multi-electron atom actually
look like.
And to do that,
we're going to look at the
radial probability distribution
function, because that tells us
a little bit about what the wave
functions look like.
Because the radial probability
distribution function,
as a function of r,
is the probability of finding
the electron a distance between
r and r plus dr.
That's what the radial
probability distribution
function tells us.
And so what I did here is to
plot the radial probability
distribution function for each
one of the electrons in the
argon atom.
Each one of the electrons in
the different states for the
argon atom.
And the first thing that I want
you to notice is that these
radial probability distribution
functions for each one of these
electrons look very similar in
shape to the radial probability
distribution functions for the
electron in a hydrogen atom.
In fact, they have the same
shape.
If you look here at the 1s wave
function, which is in green
here, you see it starts out as
zero, as all radial
probabilities do.
It increases,
goes to a maximum,
and then drops of
exponentially.
That's exactly what the 1s wave
function did in a hydrogen atom.
If you look at the 2s wave
function, it starts out at zero,
it goes to maximum,
and then there is a node.
There is a node right here.
And then it goes to another
maximum and exponentially
decays.
That's exactly what the 2s wave
function looked like in the
hydrogen atom.
For the multi-electron atoms,
these wave functions have the
same basic shape and they have
the same nodal structure.
They have the same number of
radial nodes,
same number of angular nodes.
The big difference between
these wave functions and the
hydrogen atom is the distances
from the nucleus.
For example,
if you look at the 1s radial
probability distribution for
argon, you find that that most
probable value of r is a tenth
of an a nought,
a tenth of a Bohr radius.
What was it for a hydrogen atom
in the ground state?
a nought, right?
So this 1s electron here is ten
times closer,
on the average,
in to the nucleus than the
electron in a hydrogen atom.
And the same is the case for
the 2s wave function,
2p, 3s, 3p.
It's all a lot closer in if you
compared those actual values.
And the reason it is is because
of the Coulomb attraction
between the electron and the
nucleus.
As you go to argon,
which has now a plus 18 times e
charge on the nucleus,
that's a greater attractive
interaction.
The Coulomb interaction is the
charge on the electron times the
charge on the nucleus.
It is that greater electron
attraction that pulls the
electrons in closer to the
nucleus.
That is why that 1s electron,
the most probable value of r is
at a tenth of a nought
instead of 1 a nought.
Yes?
Well, they don't collapse,
in a sense.
They don't collapse into the
nucleus.
Certainly, the probability of
finding the electron closer to
the nucleus is greater.
But it is true that as you get
larger and larger atoms,
you have more and more
electrons.
And so they do generally get
bigger.
And we will see that when we
actually look at the size and
look at the trends in the radius
as we go across and down the
periodic table.
We will look at that a little
bit more in detail,
and we will see that,
in general, if you add
electrons they get bigger.
Because you do,
in fact, have more electrons,
and you put them in these outer
shells.
But if you just do a one-on-one
comparison of 1s to 1s in
hydrogen, this is closer in,
this is closer in,
this is closer in.
Make sense?
Okay.
But now also,
since I have this diagram up
here on the board,
I want to just convey an idea
that you, I think,
are already familiar with.
And that is this idea of
shells.
When you say a shell you think
of well, the n equals 3 shell,
the n equals 2 shell,
the n equals 1 shell,
right?
But the word shell also
connotes some spatial
information.
And you can see that spatial
information here in this radial
probability distribution
function.
What I want to point out is
that the most probable value of
r for the n equals 3 shell,
well, those most probable
values aren't identical for 3p
and 3s.
But they are very similar.
They are similar compared to
the most probable value for any
electron in the n equals 2
shell.
And those are similar than the
most probable value for the
electron in the 1s shell.
So here, you can see that
spatial information.
You can see that,
on the average,
the n equals 3 shell is further
out from the nucleus than the n
equals 2 shell,
than the n equals 1 shell.
I just wanted to illustrate the
concept of shells because we had
that radial probability
distribution function up here.
And it shows you,
kind of nicely,
how those shells are indeed
separated in space on the
average.
And that is important,
as we're going to see in a
moment.
Okay, so that's a quick
description of what the wave
functions look like for the
electrons in a multi-electron
atom.
They have the similar structure
as the hydrogen atom wave
functions.
They're just all closer in
because of the charge on the
nucleus.
But now what we've got to do is
have to look at the energies of
the different states for these
electrons.
So we looked at the wave
functions.
And now we've got to talk about
the energies.
Here is that energy level
diagram for the hydrogen atom
that we drew a few days ago.
You see that the n equals 1
state here, which is the 1s
state, is lowest in energy.
The n equals 2 state here is
higher in energy.
n equals 3.
n equals 4.
And you see that we have four
degenerate states at n equals 2.
That, is the 2s state is the
same energy as all the 2p
states.
And at n equals 3,
we have 9 degenerate states.
And at n equals 4,
we've got 16 degenerate states.
But in a multi-electron atom,
that means starting with
helium, things change.
And the first big change is
that all of these energies here
are lower compared to the
hydrogen atom.
The energy of the 1s state is
lower than it is in the hydrogen
atom.
The 2s state is lower.
The 2p state is lower.
The 3s state is lower.
All of them are lower.
Why do you think that is the
case?
Anybody?
Pardon?
It's closer to the nucleus.
Yeah, it's closer to the
nucleus because the Coulomb
interaction is greater.
So that Coulomb attraction is
greater, that energy is greater,
the binding energy is greater.
It's more negative,
the same reason as the wave
functions were in closer to the
nucleus.
So these energies are lower
because of that larger
attraction because that nucleus
has a greater charge on it,
greater positive charge.
But the other thing that you
see is that the 2s state has no
longer the same energy as the 2p
state.
The 2s state is no longer
degenerate with the 2p state.
And the 3s state is no longer
degenerate with the 3p state.
And the 3p state is no longer
degenerate with the 3d state
like it is in a hydrogen atom.
How are we going to understand
that?
Why is this degeneracy broken
or lifted as it is sometimes
called?
Well, to explain that what I am
going to have to do here is to
talk about a concept called
shielding.
And shielding then is what
creates what we call an
effective charge that we're
going to talk about.
Now, to do so I want to point
out this.
That all of these binding
energies right here,
these binding energies e sub
n, but now it's e sub nl.
It depends on the angular
momentum quantum number.
Those binding energies are
minus the ionization energy of
the electron in that nl state.
That's the physical
significance of that.
But what we're going to do here
is that we're going to set that
binding energy equal to this,
this effective Z squared R sub
H n squared.
And now, I'm going to switch to
the board, and we will talk
about that a little bit and
explain this effective charge
and the shielding so that we can
understand why the 2s state is
lower in energy than the 2p
state.
I just said these states,
e sub nl,
physically significant is that
they are minus the ionization
energy.
And I'm going to approximate
that binding energy as a
hydrogen atom binding energy in
the sense that I'm going to set
that equal to that Rydberg
constant, r sub H,
over n squared,
and this is minus.
But out here I'm going to put a
Z.
This Z is not going to be the
charge on the nucleus,
but rather it's going to be
something called the effective
charge.
So Z(eff).
And it's going to depend on
both n and l quantum numbers.
This I'm calling the effective
charge.
And what I'm going to do
eventually here is to use the
experimentally measured
ionization energies to back out
an effective charge for each
electron in each n sub l state.
That's what I'm going to do.
But now what is this effective
charge?
Well, suppose I take a helium
atom and we have a nucleus here.
And the charge on that nucleus
is plus 2.
And, of course,
helium has two electrons.
And so I have,
say, an electron number one
over here and I have electron
number two over here.
But the bottom line is that for
this electron one right over
here, this electron one does not
experience the full nuclear
charge.
Why?
Because, on the average,
there's another electron in
between it and the nucleus.
And so the nuclear charge that
is experienced by this electron
is actually lower than the full
nuclear charge because this
electron here is negatively
charged.
And it, in effect,
cancels part of this positive
charge on the nucleus.
And so this electron doesn't
experience the full nuclear
charge.
It experiences something
smaller than the full nuclear
charge.
And that charge,
at something smaller than the
full nuclear charge,
is that we call the effective
charge.
How are we going to determine
that effective charge?
Well, we're going to use some
experimental measurements to do
that.
We are going to look up the
ionization energies,
or measure the ionization
energies.
And we'll see how we do that a
little bit later,
but you can guess how we do
that.
We're going to look them up and
we're going to back out the
effective charge.
So let's do that for helium.
If you go and you look up the
ionization energy for a helium
atom, you find that it is
3.94x10^-18 joules.
What I can do is I can
rearrange that equation for the
effective charge,
Zeff.
And it is n equals 1,
l equals 0.
And that will be n squared
times that ionization energy
over R sub H all to the one half
The ionization energy,
when we talk about ionization
energy, it's usually from the
ground state,
so n is going to be equal to 1
here.
The ionization energy I just
said was 3.94x10^-18 joules.
Rydberg's constant in joules is
2.180x10^-18 joules.
If I solve that I find the
effective charge is
1.34 plus.
So the charge on the helium
nucleus is plus 2,
but the effective charge for
those electrons in the helium is
less than that.
It's 1.34.
Why?
Because on the average there is
another electron in between that
electron and the nucleus.
And so the full nuclear charge
isn't experienced.
That is the effective charge.
Now this effective charge and
the physical concept here of
shielding, that's what's so
important in why the energy of
the 2s state is lower than the
energy of the 2p state.
So the energy of 2s --
An electron in the 2s state is
more strongly bound than in the
2p state.
That energy is lower than the
Why is that the case?
Well, let's think of the
lithium atom.
You know that the electron
configuration of lithium is 1s 2
2s 1.
The electron configuration of
lithium is not 1s 2 2p 1,
right?
Because that's a higher energy.
But why?
Well, to answer that we've got
to look at a radial probability
distribution again.
And I'm going to draw it for
the 2s state.
So here it is for the 2s state.
And I'm going to draw it for
the 2p state.
Here it is for the 2p state.
So this is 2p and this is 2s.
Now, we have to do a thought
experiment here.
And that is this.
If you look at the 2s radial
probability distribution
function there is a part of this
distribution function that is
really close to the nucleus.
And, for the sake of this
argument, let me say that for
this part of the radial
probability distribution
function, the effective nuclear
charge is plus 3.
Now, that is,
of course, not the case.
But bear with me for a moment.
We're saying for this part of
the radial probability
distribution function the
effective charge is plus 3.
Well, that is the nuclear
charge.
But we're saying it is close
enough.
We'll just call it plus 3.
However, for this part of the
radial probability distribution
function here for the 2s,
we're going to say the
effective charge Z(eff) is plus
1e and plus 3e here.
Why?
Well, because in lithium there
are these 1s electrons that are
really close in here.
And we're going to say that
those 2s electrons screen
completely the nuclear charge.
So you've got a Z equal plus 3
and you've got two electrons
here, electron one and electron
two, and you've got this
electron number three out here.
Since this is a minus one and
this is a minus one,
the effective charge here for
this way out electron is going
to be plus one.
But now what about the 2p
state, if we had an electron in
that 2p state?
Well, what you can see is that
because the most probable value
of r of the 2p state is in about
the same place as it is for the
2s state, it's not exactly the
same.
It's actually a little closer
in, but it's about the same
place.
We're going to say that for an
electron in the 2p state,
the effective nuclear charge is
going to be one.
But now, in order to calculate
or think about the total
effective nuclear charge,
what we're going to have to do
is to average that effective
charge over these probability
distributions.
So if the 2s probability
distribution has a part of it
where the effective charge is
plus 3 and part of it where it
is plus 1 --
If I average over that,
well, the effective charge is
going to be, I don't know,
plus 2 or something.
But for the 2p wave function,
where the effective charge is
all plus 1, it doesn't have this
lobe that is really close to the
nucleus where the effective
charge is large.
Well, that effective charge for
the 2p is going to be smaller
than it is for the 2s.
On the average here,
the effective charge Zeff,
for the 2s is going to be
greater than Zeff for the 2p
electron.
Since that effective charge is
greater, well,
we showed right up here that
the binding energy,
therefore, is going to be more
negative because that Z is
larger.
And so that's why the 2s state
is lower in energy than the 2p
and so on and so forth.
3p is lower than 3d,
etc.
Make sense?
It's because of this phenomena
of shielding and because the 2s
wave function always has this
probability of the electrons
being really close to the
nucleus where the effective
nuclear charge is larger.
If you average the nuclear
charge over the probability
distributions,
well, the effective charge for
that 2s wave function is always
going to be larger than the 2p
wave function.
Therefore, the 2s is lower in
energy than the 3p.
Okay.
That is an important point.
Now --
How do we actually write the
electron configurations for all
of the atoms in the periodic
table?
Well, I think that you already
know that we use something
called the Aufbau principle.
And the Aufbau principle is the
building up principle.
And what that says is that you
make a list here of the states
and you order the states
according to their energy,
the lowest energy at the bottom
here and then keep on going.
And we will talk about the
energies of these states in a
moment.
But then, in order to write the
electron configuration,
you start putting in electrons
into these states,
one electron at a time,
starting with the lowest energy
state.
So for hydrogen,
well, that left electron
configurations 1s.
For helium, well,
that electron configuration is
going to be 1s squared.
But you already know that we
have to put in that second
electron obeying the Pauli
exclusion principle.
So we're going to fill up these
states, one electron at a time,
lowest energy first.
And then keep going to the next
higher energy level.
And we're going to do so
heeding the Pauli exclusion
principle as we go.
So that's helium.
Here's lithium.
Now we've got lithium.
We're going to do beryllium.
Well, we have to heed the Pauli
exclusion principle.
That electron has to have the
opposite spin of this electron.
And now we come to the 2p
state.
We put an electron in the 2p
state here.
So we're at nitrogen.
And it doesn't matter whether
you put it in 2px,
2py or 2pz.
Because they have all the same
energy.
But now we have got to add
another electron.
We have got to get to carbon.
And when we get to carbon here
we're going to have to follow
something else called the Hund's
rule.
And Hund's rule says the
following.
It says that when electrons are
added to the states of the same
energy, which is what we've got
right here.
A single electron enters each
state before a second one enters
any state and the electrons,
the spins remain parallel.
So where do we put carbon's
electron?
Do we put it here?
No, because we violate
something called Hund's rule.
It means that we have to put it
in 2py or 2pz.
But do we put it in here?
No.
It's upside down.
According to Hund's rule,
the spins have to remain
parallel in order to have the
lowest energy configuration.
And so we've got to put it in
here and with the spin being
parallel to the spin of the
other electron.
So now we get to oxygen.
And we put the electron,
again, in one of the other 2p
states.
The spin has to be parallel.
And then we keep going.
Now we can start to double up
on the 2p states.
That electron goes in the other
spin.
That one goes in the other
Now we're finished with the 2p
states.
And now we're going to put the
electron in 3s state.
And the next one.
Now we're ready for the 3p
states again.
So the first one goes into one
of the 3p states,
the second one goes into one of
the other 3p states and the
spins remain parallel.
And we keep going.
So that's the Aufbau principle.
That's how you write the
electron configurations here
then for all of the atoms in the
periodic table,
heeding those two rules.
Let's take a look at this a
little more in detail.
We're going to start here just
looking at the third period,
or the third row in the
periodic table.
So we're starting here with
sodium and going across.
And here is the electron
configuration of sodium.
And you see I put two electrons
in 2px, two in 2py,
two in 2pz.
Well, if I'm just writing it
like this, I don't mind that you
just write them as 2p 6.
Because you cannot really tell
the difference here anyway.
So you can just write it as 2p
6.
Now, just a few reminders of
things that you probably already
know.
And that is that these
electrons, 1s,
2s and the 2p 6,
there are four electrons.
They make up the inner gas
configuration.
So electrons that make up an
inner gas configuration we call
our core electrons.
And this inner gas
configuration is that of neon.
And so, actually,
if you were to write the sodium
electron configuration it's fine
to just write it as neon and
then with a 3s 1
next to it.
The 3s 1,
of course, is the valence
electron.
Valence electrons are those
electrons that are beyond the
closest electron gas
configuration.
So if we went across this third
row, we would just fill up then
the 3p states.
And then we get to the
configuration,
the inner gas configuration
here of argon.
Let's look at the fourth period
here starting with potassium and
going across.
For potassium,
the electron configuration is
that of argon plus one electron.
And now, what I want you to
notice is that that extra
electron went into this 4s
state.
It did not go into the 3d
It turns out for potassium that
the 4s state is actually lower
in energy than the 3d state.
The same thing here for
calcium, the next electron,
it goes into the 4s state.
So the configuration is argon
4s 2.
It's not argon 3d 2.
4s is lower in energy than 3d.
I will show you a pneumonic in
a moment to try to remember
that.
Next scandium,
another electron.
Well, now the 3d states start
filling up.
4s 2 3d 1.
Titanium 4s 2 3d 2.
Vanadium 4s 2 3d 3.
Chromium, we have a problem.
Chromium, we've got an
exception here.
You might expect it to be 4s 2
3d 4 because
we're just filling up the d
states.
It turns out that's not the
case.
It turns out that the chromium
configuration is 4s 1 3d 5.
How do you know this?
You don't know this.
There was no way to really
predict this.
This is an experimental
observation.
It turns out that having a
half-filled 4s shell and a
half-filled 3d shell is more
stable than having a filled 4s
shell and four electrons in the
3d states.
This is an exception.
This is an exception you have
to know.
Yes?
I am going to say that in a
moment.
It is an exception also for
molybdenum.
And we'll talk about it.
It is not the exception for
tungsten or below.
So as we continue to go across,
manganese, now we're going back
to our pattern.
4s 2 3d 5.
Iron 4s 2 3d 6.
Cobalt 4s 2 3d 7.
Nickel 4s 2 3d 8.
And here we've got another
exception, copper.
Copper, if you followed our
pattern, you might expect to be
4s 2 3d 9.
It's not.
It is 4s 1 3d 10
Again, it turns out that the
overall atom is more stable if
that 4s state is half filled and
the 3d state is totally filled.
Would you be able to predict
that?
No, you're not going to be able
to predict that.
This is an experimental
observation and this is another
exception that you do have to
know.
Next, zinc.
Well, we're back to our pattern
here.
This is 4s 2 3d 10.
And then once the 3d 10
states are filled,
or the 3d states are filled,
then we start filling the 4p
states as we go across here,
this fourth row.
And we get to the krypton inner
gas configuration.
And these all follow a pattern.
Just fill the 4p states up.
So chromium and copper are two
exceptions you have to know.
Now, what happens as we go
across the fifth period here,
right here?
We're starting with rubidium.
Well, again,
the electron goes into the 5s
state and not the 4d state.
5s is lower than the 4d.
And for strontium,
the electron goes into the 5s
state, not into the 4d state.
So you fill up those 5s states
before you start filling up the
4d states here.
And just like copper and
chromium are exceptions in
filling the 3d states,
molybdenum and silver are
exceptions in filling the 4d
states.
These four exceptions,
chromium, copper,
molybdenum and silver are
exceptions that you do have to
know.
Along this fifth period here
there are other exceptions.
I don't expect you to know
that, but there are four
exceptions that you do need to
know.
Yes?
Right.
I actually don't care which way
you write the electron
configuration.
I will care if I specifically
ask you which state is lower in
energy.
But if you just write it,
I actually don't care how you
write it.
Okay?
Okay.
Now, how do you remember what
the ordering is of these states?
The energy ordering.
Well, here's a pneumonic for
you.
Maybe you've seen this before.
I'm going to start out writing
1s like this,
and then I'm going to write
right underneath it 2s and then
over one 2p, then 3s,
3p, 3d, then 4s,
4p, 4d, 4f and then 5s,
5p, 5d, 5f, 6s,
6p, 6d, 7s, 7p.
And that's all that's going to
be important right now.
And now how do I use this
pattern to generate the energy
ordering?
Well, of course,
1s is lowest.
But now I'm going to draw
diagonals through this.
So, for example,
1s is lowest.
And then the next higher energy
state is 2s.
state is 2p.
And that state after that,
that's higher in energy is 3s.
And then I draw another
diagonal so that the next higher
energy state is 3p and 4s.
And draw another diagonal 3d,
4p, 5s.
Draw another diagonal 4d,
5p, 6s.
Another diagonal 4f,
5d, 6p, 7s and another
diagonal.
So that's how you remember the
relative energy ordering of
these states.
You should be able to write the
electron configuration of all
atoms in the periodic table,
including the four exceptions.
There are other exceptions,
but I won't expect you to write
those.
Now, I have to tell you about
something that is a little
confusing.
And that is when we write down
the electron configuration of
ions.
What I'm about to say has
nothing to or doesn't change in
any way what I just told you
about writing the electron
configuration of neutrals,
but it does have something to
do in writing the configuration
of positive ions.
And here is the story.
If I actually look at the
energies of the individual 4s
states and 3d states as we go
across the fourth row,
potassium, calcium,
scandium, titanium,
well, the 4s states in
potassium and calcium are
actually lower in energy than
the 3d states.
And, indeed,
when we wrote the electron
configuration of the neutral,
we put that electron,
that extra electron making the
potassium in the 4s state and
that extra electron in the
calcium making a 4s state.
But it turns out that right at
this element,
scandium, Z equals 21,
the energy of that 3d state
drops below the energy of the 4s
state.
Does that have a consequence
for how you write the electron
configuration of scandium or
titanium, for example?
No.
The electron configuration for
titanium is still what I said,
argon, 4s 2 3d 2.
The fact that this 3d state is
now lower in energy does not
effect writing the electron
configuration of the neutral.
Now, you might ask if the 3d
states here of titanium are
lower in energy,
why don't the 4s hop over into
the 3d?
They don't because this
configuration,
again, minimizes the electron
repulsion.
If you put all four electrons
in the 3d state there would be a
greater electron repulsion and
then the overall energy would
actually be higher.
What I'm plotting here is just
the energy of 3d and just the
energy of 4s.
But when you're looking at the
electron configuration of an
ion, you have to look at all the
interactions and all of the
energies.
So for the neutral,
it's still what I said.
However, now if I form an ion,
if I take titanium and I make
titanium 2 plus,
you know the electrons that
come out?
The electrons that come out are
the electrons in the 4s state
because they're the higher
energy state.
And so the electron
configuration of titanium is the
argon 3d 2.
That is important.
And, similarly,
for that fifth row,
for rubidium,
strontium 5s is lower than 4d.
But right here at yttrium 4d
drops below 5s.
That does not effect the
configuration that we wrote for
the neutrals.
So, for example,
here is silver.
It's a 5s 1 4d 10.
But if we make a silver ion,
silver plus,
it's that 5s electron that
leaves because it's the higher
energy electron.
And so the configuration is
krypton 4d 10.
Okay.
See you on Friday.